من جانبيه قال رئيس تركيا ورجب طيب
اردوغان ان روسيا تقاومه هجوما غير محدودا
من الغرب وخاصه من الولايات المتحده مشيرا
الى ان تركيا ما زالت تسعى لحوار سلام بين
روسيا واوكرانيا اضف اردوغان انه لا ينبغي
وضع حد زمنيا لاتفاق تصدير الحبوب في
البحر الاسود
واعتبرا ان تمديد الاتفاق سيكون قرارا
صائبا واشار رئيس تركيا الى امكانيه تاسيس
طريق سلام من ممر الحبوب ورسمي حدود له
والعمل عليه بشكل جيد
دقيقه تفاصيل مع مراسيلينا من اسطنبول عمر
الحاج ومن موسكو سلام من خضر اهلا بكم معك
عمر الحاج في ثنايا هذه التصريحات الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ما توجه انقر خلال
هذه المرحله في مساله تمديد هذا الاتفاق
اتفاق تصدير الحبوب
مريم نستطيع القول ان تركيا تلعب دور
الوسيط وايضا الطرف الذي يحاول ان يبقي
كافه الاطراف قريبه من في تصريحات اردوغان
التي تحدث فيها عن اهميه
استمرار بعمله اتفاقيه الحبوب نستطيع
القول ان اردها واتفق مع كل من الجانبين
الاوكراني والروسي في هذه التصريحات فمنها
عرض النيه الروسيه وتصريحات الروسيه
السابقه التي تقول انه لابد من انهاء هذا
الاتفاق لان روسيا حتى الان هي الطرف
الخاسر من هذا الاتفاق بالرغم من انها
صاعد الى طلب الامم المتحده اضافه الوساطه
التركيه ولكنه واثق الراي الروسي مره اخرى
حين قال انه لابد من الدول التي تحتاج
فعلا الى هذه الصادرات من الاستفاده وهذا
يوافق تصريح سابقا للرئيس بوتن الذي قال
فيه ان هذا الاتفاق يرسل هذه الشحنات الى
دول اوروبيه ودول ليست بحاجه الى هذه
الشحنات ويتجاهل ااا الدول الافريقيه
ولكنهم قال مره اخرى همم ان روسيا تتعرض
لهجئ لهجوم من قبل الغرب ومن قبل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وعلى النقيض من ذلك فان
تركها تسعى لان
تلعب دور وصيه السلام والاستفاده من هذه
المبادره لتحويلها الى مبادره السلام وهذا
في حديث عن النيه التركيه تجديد المفاوضات
والدعوه لجوله مفاوضات جديده الرئيس
اردوغان ايضا
استمر في لاعب هذا الدور وان الجهد
الدبلوماسي التركي واضح مريم من خلال
استعراضنا لعدد المرات التي تقع فيها
الرئيسان او اتصلها هاتفيا خلال الاسابيع
الماضيه في الاول من نوفمبر وكان هذا
اتصال اهم في الفتره الماضيه الذي كان من
شانه ان يثني الجانب الروسي عن ايقاف
عمليه تصدير على الحبوب ذلك بعد اعلان
روسيه عن ان روسيا ستتوقف العمل ستوقف
العمل بهذا الاتفاقيه في السابع من اكتوبر
ايضا في التاسع والعشرين من سبتمبر كذلك
الامر اللقاء الذي حدث فيها اغسطس وعاقب
ذلك لقاء مع الرئيس الاوكراني اذن تركيا
هنا كما ذكر تحاول ان همم تربي همم ان
تقرب بين الاطراف توافق روسيا في بعض
الطروحات وتعرضها في طروحات الاخرى كذلك
الامر بالنسبه لاوكرانيا فهي ما تزال همم
تورد الاسلحه مهمه لاوكرانيا ولكنها بنفس
الوقت تسعى لايجاد الطريق سلام ومفاوضات
الحرب
ايضا اتفاق تصدير الحبوب والاسمده سلام
خضر ما هي ضمانات التي تحصل عليها موسكو
لتقديم تلك التسهيلات في هذا السياق
الضمان الوحيد الذي تتحدث عنه موسكو
لوجستيا اولا مريم هو ضمان وصول الاسمده
الزراعيه الروسيه والحبوب الروسيه الى دول
العالم موسكو تقولوا ان تطبيق اتفاقيه او
ما تسمى باتفاقيه البحر الاسود هي في
الحقيقه من شقين الشق الاول يتعلق بتصدير
الحبوب الاوكرانيه الى العالم الشق الثاني
يتعلق
بالسماح للصادرات الزراعيه والاسمده
الزراعيه والحبوب ايضا الروسيه بالوصول
الى دول العالم ايضا من دوني ان يكون
عليها اي عقوبات هذا الشق بالتحديد تقول
موسكو منذ اسابيع عديده ومنذ حقيقه انطلاق
تطبيق الاتفاق ان هناك عقيل تقف امام وصول
صادراتها من الاسمده الى دول العالم بل
ووصلت الى حد بالقول ان هناك دول اوروبيه
تحتجز بالفعل شحنات الروسيه من هذه
الاسمده اليوم تحدث احد ملكي احد اكبر
شركات النقل
الزراعيه هنا في روسيا وقال ان اجتماع جنب
امس
او ان الشركه التي يتراسها ستسير اول رحله
بحريه لنقل اسمده كيميائيه او زراعيه عفوا
الى ملاوي هذه قد تكون اول اشاره
عمليه وتنفيذيه للاجتماع الذي صدر الذي
حصل امس بين ممثلين عن روسيا واخرين عن
الامم المتحده الطرفان في البيان كما ذكرت
اكدى على ضروره تسهيل وصول الصادرات
الروسيه الى دول العالم قد نكون اذن اليوم
مع بيان هذه الشركه الروسيه امام اول خطوه
فعليه بالنسبه لموسكو على الاقل لارسال
هذه الاسمده التي على
لا تتواجد على الاراضي الروسيه الشركه
قالت انها تتواجد في مخازن في هولندا
وانهلندا كانت تحت جيزها ولذلك سترسل دون
مقابل الى ملاوي طبعا هذه ورقه سياسيه
ايضا بالنسبه الى روسيا
ليست فقط لوجستيه مريم شكرا جزيلا لك سلام
خضر من موسكو شكرا ايضا لعمر الحاج من
اسطنبول